hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible fighting game from round
seven now of this year's uh air things
masters it's on smokin eemon versus
magnus carlsen it's a will like i said
it's a brilliant brilliant attacking
game by both players it's a very
complicated and it's just uh one well
one big fight so
the the ending could have been a little
bit different uh but only if you played
it perfectly and we're gonna get to that
you guys will have a very nice pause the
video moment so let's dive straight into
it so neiman with the white pieces opens
with c4 he goes for the english opening
g6 by magnus we have knight to c3 and
now c5 going for the symmetrical
variation uh knight to f3 bishop to g7
and e3 now we have knight to f6 and d4
striking in the center captures captures
and now magnus castles and here we have
d5 grabbing more space in the center
looks a little bit weird because there's
really nothing there
for white to attack but if it works then
it works so e6 magnus challenges this
advanced pawn as the white king is still
in the center of the board and now
bishop to e2 of course we want to castle
the safety uh e cap percent e5c captures
and d6 now and here uh you could go for
something like castles because that's um
what people usually play here this is a
known position you don't have to worry
about bishop to g4 there there's a
bishop on e2 but for some reason neiman
first plays h3 before castling and it is
now as of move tender we have a
completely new game uh rook to e8 by
magnus and here we have castles knight
to b7 now the knight might be coming to
c5 uh we have bishop to e3 and now
magnus awaits with this knights the c5
maneuver or some other maneuver let's
say a6 b5 or whatnot uh and he goes for
the move from the thumbnail and that is
rook captures an e3 and it's just a very
nice
positional exchange sacrifice so not
gaining all that much and what's even
more interesting is that after rook
captures an e3 and f captures uh magnus
plays queen to e7 going after the e3
pawn but he's not in a rush to win it uh
as you'll see and
if white tries to defend it uh for
example with queen d2 or something like
that uh it's not all that easy to defend
uh if you play knight d1 okay you can
maybe play it like this but it's um
super passive for white and that's a no
way to play chess we can play ib6 go
after the d5 pawn and so on so instead
king the h2 first and now we have knight
to c5 again not rushing with grabbing
the pawn
now we have excellent control over the
e4 square
and now queen to d2 defending the pawn
also very interesting is b4 as b4 is
always interesting uh grabbing more
space on the queen side but then this is
very very hard to evaluate for example
captures captures uh what do you make of
this it's a it's a complete mess
you know that this knight is going to
move look at all of these dark square
holes here the e3 pawn is weak the
knight can come here the knight can come
here here uh bishop coming to e5 at some
point might be very strong so it's not
easy to assess this so instead just
queen d2 nicely defending and now we
have bishop to d7 it's time to bring the
rook into the game bishop to d3 and now
rook to e8 we have rook a to e1 now the
e3 pawn is defended and bishop to h6
magnus nope that pawn is not going
anywhere
and finally an iman plays b4 he chases
away the knight and it's uh not easy to
decide what to do here for example if
you capture on d3 that's not gonna be
great queen captures and bishop captures
and e3 looks like you've
accomplished something but there's g4
for white here and now what do you play
is bishop f for checking g2 it's not all
that impressive for black white
is definitely the one who will be
leading this game
so after b4 we have knight seat to e4 by
magnus as planned and now bishop
captures an e4 knight captures an e4 and
now queen to d4
putting more uh pressure on the knight
here so just knight captures on c3 if
magnus one he could play f5 it's also
very interesting but again uh for
example knight captures f captures
attacks the the knight here knights to
d2 now we can play bishop g7 bring the
bishop to e5 put pressure on the king we
still have to figure out what to do with
our light square bishop but it should be
playable but okay in the game knight
captures on c3 this is a bit more
straightforward queen captures and now
bishop to b5 challenging the rook here
rook to f2 and now bishop to g7 now
attacking the queen
queen back to c2 and now h5 so now the
bishop pair is very nicely placed i
wouldn't call it the fully operational
just yet but it's getting there
and now white uh has to decide whether
e4 is the move now or or or or or maybe
something else so first uh neiman plays
a4 he includes this sort of a
tempo gaining move because you gain more
space on the queen side and you will
play e4 next so it seems like it doesn't
matter uh but it seems like this move uh
only helps black because after bishop to
d7 now magnus controls the c8 square and
he will be getting rook to c8 with tempo
so e for now
now comes rook the c8 attacking the
queen and now queen to b3 uh and rook to
c3 now attacking the the white queen so
the queen has to move one once again
queen to d1 now rook the c for putting
pressure on the b4 pawn
and of course uh well the the a4 pawn is
still attacked okay the white queen is
defending it but putting a lot of
pressure on white's position uh however
here uh hans finds a very nice
advancement and that is pawn to e5 and
of course uh black does not want to give
up the dark square bishop that would be
silly uh it's pretty much why you why
you give up the exchange you want your
very strong bishop player plus it's a
very important defender so here d
captures an e5 by magnus and now d6 and
now look at this monster pass pawn
it's definitely not going to be easy to
uh to take care of it we have queen to
f6 and now uh now comes queen to d5 uh
putting putting pressure on this uh
uh rook on c4 uh now comes rook to c6 by
magnus attacking the d6 pawn and the
queen captures an e5 we have queen
captures on d6 and here we have a queen
trait we have captures captures and now
knight to g5 going after the f7 pawn so
how do you assess this position uh
magnus has five points neiman has four
pawns however niman is up the exchange
uh and attacking that f7 pawn so should
be white should be a little bit better
but in a quicker time format such as
rapid the bishop pair
well even in classical chess the bishop
pair can be very very unpleasant uh so
here bishop to f6 uh defending the pawn
by blocking it uh by blocking the rook
and now attacking the knight
knight the e for attacking both the
bishop and the rook but now bishop to e5
with check we have king to h1
and now comes rook to d4
attacking the putting pressure on the
knight and also attacking the b4 pawn so
rook to d2 offering a rook trade and now
bishop captures on a4 we are grabbing
that pawn rook captures on d4 bishop
captures and now knight to d6 so now
we are again putting pressure on f7 so
we might have some ideas of going after
that pawn also we're attacking the b7
pawn and magnus will try to utilize his
advantage on the queen side he does have
two pawns against one if he can win this
one then it's going to be very hard to
stop them so here we have bishop to c3
attacking the pawn and rook to e for now
niemann defends the pawn we have b5 now
uh and rook to e8 with check here he
abandons the defense of this pawn in
order to get uh
get to this pawn uh to get to the f7
pawn we have rooked the e8 with check
king to g7 and now rook the e7 so now we
will be capturing this pawn because if
bishop defense then you you of course
give up the b5 pawn so bishop captures
on b4 we have rook captures on f7 with
check and now king to h6 uh you could
also play king to g8 it is possible then
we just unpin with uh rook here and we
defend our knight but this is a much
more interesting king to h6
and now there are all sorts of
checkmating uh patterns possible here
and neiman goes knight to e4 and his
plan now is h4 create an outpost for the
knight on g5 and then play rook to h7
checkmate so can magnus do anything
about this
let's see magnus starts by pushing a5
now of course he wants to start pushing
those pawns and if he he can be in time
to defend against this checkmate then
it's a good idea we have h4 preparing
this checkmate now comes bishop b3 we
have to move with tempo we attack the
rook
rook to a7 and now a4 so look at all of
the squares that the bishops are
covering imagine if this bishop is on uh
on b2 then all of these squares uh are
covered and then you just push the pass
pawn there's nothing white can do about
this so if this bishop comes here it's
game over so here we have g4 uh uh
interestingly if knight g5 then you do
not have checkmate magnus can block with
bishop to g8 so that's the problem for
niemann so he tries something else g4
yeah he finds a different mating net uh
h count percent g4 and now knight to f6
again putting pressure on black now uh
rook h7 is the threat of checkmate as
the pawn covers the g5 square so g5 now
clearing the g6 square for the king and
now h5 not taking away the g6 square
from carlson's king and now again rook
to h7 is the threat of checkmate so
bishop to c2 now guarding against
checkmate and now
uh the position is winning for magnus
unless uh white finds uh well uh it's
such a move that uh you you don't expect
anyone to find unless it's a it's in a
really important classical game where
you have a lot of time on the clock but
you guys are comfortable in your own
homes you have plenty of time i hope so
you have time to crack this one it's not
easy feel free to pause the video and
try to find the only move that saves the
game for neiman
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
to do it congratulations as this is one
of the hardest positive video moments uh
you've probably seen on this channel in
a very long time or or maybe ever
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is rook to a6 uh if
you found this one without uh figuring
out why then you have great intuition
and you should you know
hone it
but if you found everything then that's
just incredible you are you are way too
strong to be watching this channel
however we are going to show why this is
so incredible so the thing is we are now
threatening some very nasty discoveries
like maybe we can play knight's d5 check
and pick up the bishop and then we're
not going to lose the game so of course
black will play something like bishop to
a3 black and play other moves i'm just
showing the the strongest ones now comes
the hard part okay so you got this far
how do you how do you save the game now
we're still uh just going to push our
pawns and win the game here comes knight
to e4 with check and now the problem is
black cannot capture this pawn if you
capture the pawn knight the g3 check and
now look at this the black king cannot
go up the board you have to go here and
now king g2 threatening uh rook to h6
checkmate and now after bishop prevents
this let's say bishop to f8 uh you want
to stop this now rook c6 we attack the
bishop here and after you move the
bishop now comes rook to c1 and you're
getting checkmated here so
not possible to defend okay you can play
bishop e4 check and give up the bishop
but you will still lose this game
so that's not happening so the other
thing you can do after knight to e for
check is not go capture the pawn
but that means you have to go up the
board so king g7 now we continue with h6
check as the pawn is nicely defended
king to f8 now comes rook to a8 with
check and now we will most likely see a
perpetual king to f7 rook to a7 check
king to g6 rook to a6 check and now
black will either repeat by going up the
board or black can even go king to f5
but it's not a problem knight to c3 and
now look at this the knight is guarding
uh this diagonal so now h7 h8 is a huge
threat and you don't have time for
bishop to b2 because the knight is here
or rather you have to play bishop to
beat you right away to be in time to
stop the pawn but that just means after
bishop b2 we will play knight captures
on b5 eliminate one of black's very
strong past pawns and now we are
guarding the a3 square uh and all of
your uh troubles uh are are over well
not all of them you still have to play
uh i play precisely for example if
bishop here attacks the knight we can
just play h7 and now look look at this
if bishop captures on b5 rook b6 now you
can't move the bishop because we pick up
this bishop and we promote this pawn to
a queen so it's a complete madness uh
well that was in the position because
the game was so crazy uh and after
crosstalk's bishop to c2 uh uh it was
possible uh to to escape however only if
you find this incredible resource of
rook to a6 nieman in the game played
king the g2
sort of the the a similar idea of course
the checkmating patterns exist and you
want to be closer to king to g3 but now
magnus is uh well just in time for
bishop to c3 now you move with tempo the
knight is attacked knight to g8 with
check and now king captures an h5 now
the problem is you can capture the h5
pawn because after rook to a6 which was
played yes neiman is again threatening
checkmate now there's bishop to e for
check king the g3 and the bishop to e5
check we have king f2 now g3 with check
creating a very important escape square
for the black king king the e3 and now
yes your bishop is attacked but magnus
just placed g2 and it was in this
position on move 54 that han smoke and
neiman resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so really
like like i announced an incredible
fighting game uh very early exchange
sacrificed by magnus niemann played it
uh extremely well he got that a very
nice e6 uh upon sacrifice with advancing
the pawn uh e5 and advancing the pawn to
d6 it was everything was incredible and
then the game could have ended in a draw
but uh that incredible rook the a6 move
was required and i mean that's just too
much for for a rapid game so here okay
you resign because if you capture the
bishop black gets a queen into the game
uh so that's not happening and of course
if you try and stop the pawn bishop d
for check and next we're getting a queen
into the game so whatever you play loses
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it really an incredible one
there are of course so many games being
played i only cover
one or two maybe sometimes three of them
depending on how much time i i have
so feel free to use hashtag suggestion
and if i will have more time i will of
course go through your suggestions and
cover as many games as possible uh so
yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it a tough break for hans but he
played a brilliant game
i would like to thank lucifer 45
non-commercial ep dale cook anwar the 95
american flag numa david kimura and doug
reynolds for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this uh
wonderful event
until it finishes uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day